Nó đây chúng ta cảm giấu rằng sự mạnh của đất nước không chỉ được đó bằng kinh tế,
cuộc phòng, hay bằng bị thế cuộc tế mà còn là cách chân trọng qua khứ,
trong đó những người cũng diền bởi vì trọng tình nghĩa, quên như vậy đã hầy sĩ.
Đất nước cảm phát triển, người có công của gia đình cảm phẩy là trong đó tôi đơn,
đó là chắc hiện chính trị đã bối lý dân tập, tức đó,
và tình in văn của chế độ của xa hội.
Chiến thì không thể chỉ dừng lại, cũng có hòa của sình qua,
hay những cuộc tham hỏi trong thống bệnh.
Chiến và hiện giải trong chính sách đầy đủ,
thực hiện đúng lúc trong mãi nghe an toàn trong phát độ điều chỉ vua.
Trong cuộc cấp dữ kìa thầy trong cơ hội học tập,
bệ hạ ngủ, con chống, những người có cơ.
Trong thái độ, nâng nghe, người dạ cơm, người có chắc nghe,
người có cơm, người có cơm.